thing all right give me the trivia
question all right so the steelers at
6-0 are the last undefeated team this
season who was the last undefeated team
last season
wow
well it wasn't the 49ers they lost early
and the ravens ended up with a 1c but
they were 2 and 2. the last undefeated
team last year
i was oh man last year the last
undefeated team the packers
you said it you were right it was the
49ers the 49ers yeah remember they
started out
they had not lost until that game
against seattle at home with you know
the opening oh football that was an
awesome game that was jadav and
clowney's tour de force yeah all right
well i said it does that count
nope
all right sorry slugger can i get a
bingo
all right go ahead yeah pete's mad at me
go ahead
i think the first pick the the
the the bill's offense of weapons versus
the patriot secondary is one of the
matchups i'm looking at for this week i
mean because there's a lot of things
that encompass this i mean of course we
know what's happening you blew it you
blew it you blew it you i was yeah
stefan versus stefan how can you not go
stefan versus stefan that's the that's
great when do we ever have a chance to
say staphon versus okay put it on there
it's stefan versus staphon all right
it's two different spellings of it too
it's a ph and an f version so i like
that but either way just like just like
john coffey from green mob
same as the drink just spelled different
go ahead yes but
i i mean
that matchup of course is gold it's
going to be all the matchups across the
board and where i'm excited because the
bills can't run the football they're all
about throwing the patriots can't stop
running the run they're all about past
defense and then of course brian dayball
he's a new england disciple him there as
the offensive coordinator matching wits
with the belichicks and that all that
that's going to be very interesting to
me and that'll be the story of the game
really you know can that can the bills
consistently throw the ball on new
england if they can they're going to win
the game if it's tough
uh i think they could be in trouble of
being upset by the patriots
yeah look i agree with you and that was
one of the ones on my list obviously
because i had the stefan and stefan
locked and loaded and ready to go i am
gonna go something we talked about
earlier lamar jackson versus that
steelers front seven we know how the
steelers take pride in stopping the run
they get off the bus stopping the run
that was cam hayward told me a couple of
weeks ago when they shut down the browns
running game they've only faced lamar
jackson once before they're going to be
ready and they've just got that swagger
and let's see what lamar jackson has he
had a week off to get ready for this one
heal up any lingering knicks he may have
you know he popped up from time to time
on the injury report
this is going to be a great one what
does lamar have can he throw the ball
against that defense but most
importantly running the ball strength on
strength what can lamar do against that
front seven yeah i'm that's gonna be
awesome i mean just two bullies on the
field as far as teams are concerned and
it's just like which one will break or
which one will blink i mean that that's
i'm
um is that the game of the day i mean is
that the game of the day to you on
sunday i guess so i think it's the game
of the day for me
all right yeah i think yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah because the ravens have
one loss and this is gonna be this is
the biggest test left on the steelers
regular season schedule so yes yep all
right um i think the next one i'm gonna
go to is flores versus mcveigh
you know again here we are it's the tua
the tua you know showing up there for
the miami dolphins what can they do but
i think this is a game that i would not
be shocked if miami pulled off an upset
i'm not saying i'm gonna pick them but i
don't think you can just chalk it up to
oh the rams are five and two
and they got mcvay and aaron don they're
just going to roll over this miami
dolphins team i don't think that'll be
the case i don't and i think you know
really the big factor of the game will
be flores can he
slow down mcveigh and jared goff and
robert woods and all those things on the
offensive side of the ball to let tua
get ready and into the game a little bit
you know if it comes out with mcveigh
and they're just it's surgical and
mcgenius is going down the field and all
that stuff and all of a sudden tua is
like getting the ball and he's down
seven nothing he goes three and out and
all of a sudden now it's 14 nothing like
forget it they got no chance so it will
be important for the defense and flores
to break out that game plan we saw from
the super bowl a few years ago with the
patriots versus the rams and do some
other stuff to give them a chance to win
the football game and give a chance to
tour to win his first start as a as a
left-handed quarterback
yeah i mean it could end up being like
the 49ers patriots game last week where
you sputter a few times and the next
thing you know it's 23 to three exactly
right it could be and you're done and
you're okay next one for me
i'm gonna go dk metcalf against the 49er
secondary whoever it is that draws the
short straw on any given play because i
think metcalf is going to be pissed off
because
not that he's going to be mad that he
didn't get the ball more last week just
that he didn't get open more often that
he didn't do well enough that he didn't
put himself in position to get the ball
and i i think he's going to have a huge
game and i think whoever is trying to
cover him from that secondary is going
to wish they didn't have to cover i i
would think that would be back to back
to the basics for the seattle seahawks
first off
san francisco plays so many single
safety defenses where either a zone or
man it plays like man-to-man one-on-one
on the outside
and that's one of the weaknesses to me
of that 49ers defense you could throw it
out there if you're willing to do it and
russell wilson and them are and russell
wilson let arizona as i said earlier in
the week
off the hook last week there was too
many times where it was d.k metcalf man
to man you should have thrown the ball
to dk metcalf and for some other reason
he worked the other side of the ball and
i would think he got he saw that film
and went wait what the hell was i doing
why didn't i work him more uh so i
expect that to happen all right i'm
going to go to the browns raiders game
um
sneaky big time game here you know
because of course there's playoff
implications here the raiders they can't
afford to really lose this so they might
fall out of favor and fall out of the
race for a playoff spot and of course we
know the browns are kind of in the
similar scenario to me the big battle
here for this football game will be
can the raiders defensive line
not get mauled by the browns offensive
line that's really where it'll come down
to because i think it's the raiders will
be able to cover the browns in a lot of
ways the browns running game can really
dominate and and it makes life easy for
baker mayfield sometimes raiders are not
impressive up front if they could slow
it down a little i think they'll be able
to cover the browns without obj and all
that and to where maybe they can pull
off an upset in cleveland but i'm just
not sure what happens there in that
matchup
yeah i thought about going john gruden
against the virus but that's not a
matchup because as we know the raiders
are on the cutting edge
of beating them they dominated it
next one for me le'veon bell against
adam gase oh yeah hey look damn i
thought i forgot about that regardless
of how it came out how it played out
gay you know it was characterized as
gays didn't want bell the truth is gase
didn't want to pay bail 13.5 million per
year gase recognized that
you can't have bell as the finishing
touch to an offense that otherwise has
nothing it was too much money to invest
in the position when you have far more
important needs in crafting an offense
but they never got along they never saw
eye to eye the relationship was poisoned
from the get-go and this is bell's
chance i mean this is it man i mean what
what did what did gates do to deserve
this season and he's going into the bye
with games against the chiefs and then
the patriots and he gets le'veon bell in
bell's second game on the field with the
chiefs so that one's easy for me is that
have we done three each all right that
was it that was fast
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports